Benjamín netanyahu volverá a ser Primer
Ministro de Israel y lo hace más a la
derecha que nunca en la noche del
miércoles minutos antes de la fecha
límite neton yajule comunicó al
presidente Isaac hersock que había
logrado formar gobierno
[Música]
quiero hacerles saber que gracias al
enorme apoyo público que recibimos
durante las elecciones puedo formar un
gobierno que cuidará de todos los
ciudadanos de Israel y por supuesto
Tengo la intención de establecerlo Tan
pronto como sea posible
su gobierno que se compondrá de 64 de
los 120 legisladores de laneset aún
tiene que ser ratificado por el
parlamento encabezada por el licut la
coalición contará con otros cinco
partidos Ultra ortodoxos religiosos y de
extrema derecha netanyahu ha estado
insistiendo en que representará a todos
los israelíes una respuesta a las dudas
que hay en torno a sus socios un partido
procolonos tendrá la autoridad en la
planificación de cisjordania Mientras
que el Ministerio de Justicia de la
policía quedarán manos de benvie quien
tiene opiniones como esta la gente
quiere una separación absoluta entre los
leales al Estado de Israel con los que
no tenemos ningún problema y aquellos
que socavan la existencia de nuestro
querido estado
netanyahu estuvo durante 15 años en el
cargo un récord su objetivo la
estabilidad para un país que ha acudido
cinco veces a las urnas en menos de 4
años y el cual ha vivido el año más
violento en una década con más de 150
palestinos y 20 israelíes asesinados